mesdames messieurs bonsoir c'est par une
information de dernière minute que nous
ouvrons ce journal quatre personnes sont
en effet gardé à vue dans le cadre de l'
enquête sur l'assassinât du petit
grégory vous savez ce petit garçon
retrouvé noyé pieds et poings liés dans
la rivière proche de la maison de ses
parents les enquêteurs avaient fait
porter leurs recherches sont les proches
de la famille est apparemment ce soir
ils sont parvenus à trouver une piste
isabelle bechler le choc psychologique
des funérailles de grégory a peut-être
comme le souhaitaient les gendarmes
permis de rompre le silence de la
famille samedi dernier tout le monde
sait piet tout le monde pensait que
l'assassin était au cimetière cet après
midi à 17h30 une jeune femme lointaine
parente des villemin a tenu à témoigner
à la gendarmerie elles auraient apporté
des informations décisives
une demi heure plus tard 18 heures deux
couples étaient conduits à la
gendarmerie
un couple jeune et un couple plus âgé
selon des témoins ils portaient des
objets dont des cassettes des
cordelettes et de petites bottes vertes
ces quatre personnes sont actuellement
gardés à vue par les gendarmes de
bruyères les gendarmes qui ont également
gardé à vue la femme qui a témoigné plus
tôt dans l'après midi
mais là sans doute pour la protéger
l'enquète semble donc s'accélérer les
gendarmes ont également diffusé ce soir
le premier portrait robot de l'assassin
de grégory il s'agirait d'un homme d'un
mètre 75 à 1 mètre 80 qui porte des
lunettes ses cheveux serait mi longs et
bouclés brin on l'aurait vu vêtu d'un
pull de couleur bordeaux et chaussé de
bottes
l'enquète débouchera peut-être au
courant de la nuit